[Musique]
m
oui ta mère wen
j'ai dîné dans un avion papa maman t'es
pas là
alors papa le vol s'est bien passé on
s'en fout tu m'a demandé de venir te
chercher
tu t'en souviens je n'aurais jamais
demandé sa tête
car tu sais que maman d'état là
tu as oublié parce que tu es trop vieux
tu ressembles à une conversion
puis savais que tu étais [ __ ] de l'armée
je ne savais pas vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attac mois tant que tueur et mais je ne
rentre plus dans ton jeu
quand un type de montage se dit qu'ils
enrichissent et c'est qu'il l'a déjà
faire tu crois que je ne vois pas venir
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un gros con toi qu'une
pauvre pédales
est et des papables
[Musique]
radi neveu meyer